Google Cloud updates
so the modernization imperative is a new
blog series from our leadership that
seeks to enthusiastically over share on
all things Tech and accordingly we'll be
abbreviating it TMI check out the first
edition all about the strategy of
Shifting down and relying on managed
resources to relieve burdens on
developers which we love and speaking of
new series you might have missed the
first installment of cloud econ 101 a
new bi-weekly Cloud series all about
optimizing tools streamlining workloads
and aligning technology goals to drive
business value check out the links below
for everything we covered on this week's